the remains of the vehicle in which the
Iranian General and the Iraqi militia
leader were riding when the American
missiles struck soleimani had just
landed at Baghdad Airport
Mohandas was on hand to welcome him both
were killed instantly along with at
least five others the deaths are a major
setback for Iran which loses its most
powerful and most popular military
commander and an important Iraqi ally
the reaction from Tehran came quickly
supreme leader Ayatollah Ali Khamenei
ordered three days of mourning and
issued a statement promising a quote
strong revenge against the criminal
killers of general Soleimani at Friday
prayers worshippers chanted
anti-american slogans and vowed revenge
how stupid can they be to do such a
thing
because in the Middle East I think Iran
is the factor of stability and Qasem
Soleimani was an influential factor in
that stability the entire nation of Iran
all the Islamic countries we are all
general Soleimani and we will never let
the u.s. do anything this action which
US officials have apparently taken
responsibility for you can be sure it
was an amateur act Iran will wake up and
produce more sulamani I assure you in
Iraq some celebrated Salah manis death
many Iraqis disapprove of Iran's strong
influence on the country's politics but
Iraq also has a large Shiite population
that sees Iran as a friend
above all Iraqis fear being dragged into
a u.s. Iranian conflict America and Iran
should solve their problems outside Iraq
we don't want them to solve them inside
Iraq because that doesn't serve our
interests the people who have gathered
here aren't celebrating the killing of
suleimani or anyone else because it
doesn't serve us at the end of the day
kill em without the conflict was already
ratcheting up before this latest
airstrike on Thursday 750 American
soldiers arrived in Kuwait now
Washington has directed US citizens in
Iraq to get out of the country
immediately and for more on this story
I'm joined in the studio by Guido
Steinberg from the German Institute for
international security affairs and US
political analyst Rachel Rizzo Guiteau
can you give us a sense of just how much
potential this airstrike has to unleash
turmoil in an already extremely volatile
region you can't overstate the
importance of general Soleimani for
Iranian expansion in in recent years he
has been the general of his generation
in the Iranian military so the Iranians
from their point of view will have to
react and the problem is that they have
already escalated the conflict with the
United States just think of the Iranian
attacks on the Saudi oil installations
in September the next logical step I
think would be first to kill Americans I
think that is what's going to happen not
imminently but perhaps after some months
and the Iranians will try very hard to
evict the United States forces from Iraq
Rachel what do we know about how this
u.s. decision was made would President
Trump have given the the go-ahead fully
aware of the the possible consequences
so this attack this killing was directed
by President Trump himself the
Department of Defense tweeted that this
was a defensive just decisive action
directed by the president the question
is what comes next and has the u.s.
national security apparatus been working
behind the scenes and are they prepared
to have a response from the United
States depending on how Iran decides to
respond okay well we'll talk more about
the implications of his death in a
moment but first let's take a closer
look at the at this significance
as commander of the elite codes force of
Iran's Revolutionary Guard Qasem
Soleimani was Iran's top general he was
also its most recognizable and popular
military commander supreme leader
Ayatollah Ali Khamenei once called him a
living martyr of the Revolution
Soleimani joined Iran's Revolutionary
Guard after the Iranian Revolution in
1979 he saw action in the eight-year
iran-iraq war in 1998 he became
commander of the Kurds force that
conduct seiran's clandestine and foreign
military operations the u.s. considered
him a terrorist and blamed his goods
force for the deaths of hundreds of
American soldiers soleimani was
especially active in Iranian operations
against rebel groups in Syria against
the so-called Islamic state and
supporting Shiite militias in Iraq over
the years Soleimani survived a number of
scrapes with death including an airplane
crash in 2006 and a bombing in Damascus
in 2012 he was 62 years old when an
American missile killed him in Baghdad
Quito
what was this top Iranian general doing
in Iraq he's an Iraqi politician the the
cuts force is responsible for Iranian
foreign policy in the Eastern Arab world
especially Iraq Syria Lebanon and he has
been called the most influential person
in Iraq by Iraqi politicians in in
recent years in fact in order to become
prime minister in Iraq you needed the
consent of hassan Soleimani
already in 2006 and 2010 2014 and 2018
again so it was quite a routine event
and he was visiting his friend Abu
Martin mohandas the head of the
Hezbollah brigades these are the closest
ally of the Iranian Kurds force the guy
who has been killed with him and the
militia responsible for the attacks on
Americans in recent weeks and the
militia mainly responsible for the
attack on the American Embassy just
three or four days ago
Rachel let's have a look at the US now
what's the reaction been in the u.s. to
Soleimani is killing politically but
also from the public unsurprisingly the
reaction has been pretty divided amongst
political lines so this killing was
carried out without the knowledge of top
congressional senators like Chuck
Schumer and congresswoman Nancy Pelosi
and you've gotten tweets from some
Republicans like Ben Sasse Tom cotton
Lindsey Graham saying that this attack
was coming the Iranians have been
punching the US and the nose for long
enough and they they should have
expected it and they deserved it
Democrats on the other hands have had a
very different reaction saying that yes
Soleimani had blood on his hands but
this is an escalation for which the US
might not be prepared and so when
Congress comes back from its recess next
week we can expect them to kind of start
looking at checking the the president's
War Powers but as you saw from Trump's
tweet just the American flag he's going
to use this to try to drum up support
from his base does this attack figure in
any kind of plan the strategy that
President Trump has for the Middle East
so the question is you know does Trump
have a strategy in the Middle East and
if so what is it obviously countering
Iranian influence as well as supporting
US allies Saudi Arabia and Israel is a
mainstay of that but this killing I
think puts the US administration as well
as diplomats and forces abroad in an
impossible spot because now the
administration has to strategize and
think five or six steps ahead and given
that the President himself is sort of a
rogue actor and likes to you know very
act very impulsive ly this is going to
be pretty difficult a difficult one for
for the u.s. to navigate guida can we
get your take on that can the
international community discern any
coherent Middle East strategy from
Washington right now there is nothing
like an international community and
especially not in this regard we have
seen an escalation between the Iranians
and the United States in recent months
and the problem about this escalation is
that the United States I think doesn't
have a strategy
maximum pressure is not a strategy it's
not clear what they want and I would
have expected a military response by the
latest after the attack on the Saudi oil
installations it has been US policy to
protect the Gulf states from any kind of
attacks since since President Carter the
Carter doctrine in 1980 and President
Trump didn't follow up on his threats
and I think that was the mistake
that prompted the the Iranians to
escalate they thought they could get
away with anything such a kind of attack
and targeted assassination of a regular
military commander should only happen if
you are ready for military conflict and
the Trump administration is obviously
not not yet at least not before the
elections all right we'll have to leave
it there Guido Steinberg and Rachel
Rizzo thanks so much for your analysis